Ural Mountains are
very old mountains
stretching from the Russian
north to the Russian south.
It kind of splitting
Russia into two parts--
Europe and Asia.
Indeed, people living
in the Ural Mountains
witness some strange phenomena
in the air and on the ground.
NARRATOR: Dozens of visitors
to the Ural Mountains
have reported strange sightings
of fireballs and cigar shaped
crafts, but even
stranger is what has
been found in the earth here.
In 1991, geologists
led an expedition
into the mineral
rich Urals in hopes
of locating gold deposits.
While excavating sites near the
Kozhim, Narada, and Balbanyu
rivers, just 600
miles north of Arkaim
the scientists discovered
something unexpected.
At depths of over 30
feet, they unearthed
a scattering of tiny
metal coils and springs.
That soil was untouched
for hundreds of thousands
or more years.
The area where it was found
was probably tens of kilometers
around.
It's as if something exploded
thousands of years ago
and the fragments were
lying all over the place.
NARRATOR: The metal fragments,
some as small as 1/10,000
of an inch, were sent to the
Russian Academy of Sciences
in St. Petersburg for analysis.
Their shape resembled
manufactured technology
rather than naturally
occurring minerals.
The smallest pieces were
found to be tungsten,
a metal used in
spacecrafts and missiles
due to its ability to
withstand high temperatures.
They are these metal
spirals that consist of copper
but also tungsten
and molybdenum, which
are both very rare metals.
We're looking at nanotechnology.
DAVID WILCOCK: When you look
down at them in a microscope,
they're extremely regular
in their structure.
They're very nice coils.
The only way we
could make them even
now is with machine
guided technology.
You could not do this by hand.
What we're seeing here
is proof that someone
had advanced technology
sufficient to build
the type of circuitry
that we normally
only see in semiconductors--
computer chips, high technology
equipment using metals
that are not commonly known.
So these spirals
are clear evidence
that someone had a very
advanced civilization right
here on Earth near Arkaim.